la tristesse la colère ces sentiments
nous rende plus fort seulement
on change aussi profondément
ne pensons pas passé mais plutôt au
futur
j'ai le sentiment qu'il veut continuer
ce qu'il a commencé ce jour là ce projet
qui l'a conçu de reprendre le contrôle
de la planète afin de pouvoir en devenir
le maître en compagnie de genova
[Musique]
tt étendues sur le sol alors j'ai pensé
que c'était trop tard tu veux dire que
tu crois que je suis morte que je suis
pas là même type à quelle époque c'est
ça
[Musique]
je comprends pas il ya cinq ans est-ce
qu'on serait venu ici ensemble zac ou
est ce qu'il est maintenant
c'est toi
ce que je vois
désolé
je sais pas comment tenir
[Musique]